sometimes people dress like a certain
degree of the Limelight and if you're a
non-effective republican the media loves
you so of course here he is on CNN the
media wants to prop him up because they
know it will hurt Trump say Trump slash
dissatis take a look
um Trump uh last night in response to
you running ran a rather mocking uh
video on social media
um there it is it's it's you uh I guess
he's he's making fun of your weight
um that's his uh
that's his response what did you make of
that what was your response to that you
know uh when I saw Jake I just renewed
in my own mind what a child he is he's a
baby
um whenever you want to criticize him I
mean anyway that's the way he responds
and you and I are both lucky enough to
be parents
um and if we had a child who conducted
themselves like that
um we'd send them to their room yeah not
to the White House yeah um and I think
character is Destiny
for this country and we've got to make a
decision about what the character of the
person should be who sits behind the
desk in the Oval Office and if they're
going to do that kind of stuff I mean it
doesn't even it's it's so childish it's
so juvenile he is such a spoiled baby
that you know I beyond that what can you
even say about something like that
that's that ridiculous you know I didn't
if we want to break news here today
um I struggled with my weight for about
20 years like tens of millions of
Americans the devil you said right
exactly
um so he's breaking news there he's
telling people something they don't know
um in the end for me
um it's about how you perform as a
person yeah what kind of heart you have
and I'll put mine up against his any day
in the week you know I am kind of over
the antic stuff with Trump and like that
that whole thing I I actually don't
think it works I guess it was refreshing
that it went to somebody else instead of
DeSantis for one day but what do you
make of of that thing with Trump and
this point
I mean I'm not I'm not a trump supporter
I never was and uh this to me looks more
the same I actually think Trump had a
lot of brilliant policies I mean I lived
in Israel for 20 years until pretty
recently and
he changed life he changed life in the
Middle East that's a fact however I
agree with what Christie says there that
character is destiny that that's what
matters in the white house and I agree
with that with regard to Trump but I
also agree with that with regard to
Christie himself I mean this is a guy
who for political Revenge shut down
Lanes of one of the most important
bridges in New York City to get revenge
on some mayor from Jersey for not voting
for her not endorsing him for for mayor
I'm sorry for for governor
thousands and thousands of people
suffered from that every single day
sitting in traffic because he wanted to
to to have this Petty revenge on this
mayor and again with the beach thing you
know he's sitting on a beach that he
shut down that is not character and
that's why I you know Chris Christie's
way to me makes no difference I don't I
wouldn't make fun of someone because of
that I think that's wrong of course it's
the actual actions in office that
Christy took that still irk me and I was
in New York during that time 2014-15 I
could see the traffic and you think this
was just one guy's whim and one guy
exacting revenge and this is the guy who
is now casting aspersions on somebody
else's character yeah I remember that I
mean he closed down these Lanes the
George Washington Bridge it was a big it
was a big scandal at the time